[Müzik]
aşkın rengi olan Kırmızının üzerinde
durmak O yüzden kırmızı giydin zaten
Aşk insanı varoluşundan bu yana
anlamlandırmaya çalıştığı ve içine
doldurmaya çalıştığı bir kelime
ve aşk insanların kendi yaşam
öykülerinin aslında bir serüveni kendi
yazdıkları senaryoların Hayat bulmuş
hali
şu an
teknolojik gelişmelerle birlikte biz
aşkı sadece felsefeyle değil aslında
biyolojik olarak da tanımlama şansına
sahip oluyoruz beyinde neler oluyor
beden derinliler oluyor
nörokimyasallarımız nasıl değişiyor ve
bunları bir araya getirdiğimiz zaman
yeni çağda aşkın tanımı değişmeye
başlıyor
önce Aşkın herkeste ortak olan bazı
belirtileri ile başlayacağım çünkü aşkı
tanımlarken Öncelikle bedenimizde olan
hissiyatlarla tanımlıyoruz bu neredeyse
hepimizde ortak hissiyatlara sahip ortak
belirtilerle gösteriyor
karnımızda Kelebekler uçuşması nefes
alıp verişimizde hızlanma
zihnimizde düşünme merkezlerimizin bloke
olmasıyla düşünme yetimizi kaybetmeye
başlamak
kaslarda kasılma derleme
ellerde uyuşma ayaklarda uyuşma gibi
neredeyse Bu belirtiler aşık olan tüm
insanın tüm insanların tanımladığı ortak
belirtiler
bunu sempatik sistem dediğimiz sempatik
sinir sistemi dediğimiz bir sistem
aracıyla gerçekleştiriyor sempatik
sistem aslında bir tehdit veya heyecan
durumunda Vücudun bir yanıt vermek için
kendisini hazırlaması kan akımının
kaslara yönlendirilmesi gereksiz
organlardan çekildiği için kan akımı
artık kaslara yönlendirilebilmek için
ihtiyaç duymayacağımız o heyecan ya da
stres anında ihtiyaç duymayacağımız
organlardan çekilmesi ile birlikte
gerçekleşiyor Örneğin sindirim sistemi
sindirim sistemine Kaçarken veya
savaşırken veya heyecan anında ya da
stresle mücadelede sindirmeye yemek
yemeye ihtiyacımız olmayacağı için
oradan çekilen
kan aracılığıyla burada bir gurultu
oluşmaya başlıyor bu bölgede kalp daha
hızlı pompalamaya kaslara kaslar Kaçmak
için kullanacağımız için kan daha hızlı
kaslara pompalanmaya başlıyor da olarak
çarpıntımız olmaya başlıyor ilk açarken
düşünme ihtiyacımız yok çünkü
kurtulmamız gerekiyor o durumdan o
stresi durumdan beyinden de çekiliyor ve
düşünemiyoruz baktığınız zaman sempatik
sistemin belirtileri aşkta olan
belirtiler
bunu başka bir yerde daha yaşıyoruz
Aslında ormanda ya da Doğada Bir
yürüyüşe çıktınız ve bir ayıyla
karşılaştığınızı düşünün vücut oradan
kaçabilmek adına sempatik sistemi aktive
ediyor sindirim sisteminden karına
çekiyor beyinden kanı çekiyor Siz artık
nasıl bir kaçış yolu Düşünmeniz
gerektiğine odaklanmıyorsunuz sadece
kaçmaya odaklanıyorsunuz orada ayı ile
ilgili hiçbir veriyi hiçbir bilgiyi
işlemiyorsunuz sadece tehdit
altındasanız ve kaçmanız gerekiyor
Aslında baktığınız zaman aşık
olduğumuzdaki belirtilerle neredeyse
birebir aynı şeyi yaşıyoruz bu bizim
ayıya aşık olduğumuz anlamına geliyor mu
tabii ki gelmiyor ayı bir tehdit aşık
olduğumuz kişi de onun yanında olma
isteği ve bağlanma isteği uyandıran kişi
fakat Aşkın gözü kördür beyinden bu
kadar kan akamını çekersen düşünemeyince
Tabii ki aşkın gözü ya da beyni kör
olmaya başlıyor ve bir süre sonra bu
etkiler geçecek Tabii ki yani
vücudumuzun hormonal sistemi hiçbir
zaman Daimi sürekli bir sağlık şeklinde
çalışmaz tükenir artar ve giderek azalır
azalmaya başladığında o etki geçiyor
yapılan araştırmalar o aşk diye tabir
ettiğimiz hissiyatlarının en fazla 2 yıl
kadar sürdüğünü göstermiş iki yıl sonra
o gözünüzdeki perde kalktığı zaman işte
o zaman karşınızdaki ayıyı görüyorsunuz
Belki de bu yüzden
Hani bir süre sana karşımızdakini ayır
dememizin anlamı bu olabilir
Peki Aşk Sadece biyolojik bir sistemle
mi ilerliyor Tabii ki hayır aşkım bir
varoluşsal felsefesi de var dünyaya
gelişimizden itibaren
bizim yaşam öykümüzle birlikte yoğrulan
ve şekillenen bir anlamı da var dünyaya
geldiğimiz ilk anda bu hayata adımız
attığımız ilk anda biz
bir meme ararız neden hayatta kalabilmek
için bu içgüdüsel bir şeydir
içgüdüsel bir arayışla birlikte
kendimizi hayatta Tutabilecek ilk
nesneye anneme mesele yöneliriz ve ilk
bağlanmayı anne memesiyle
gerçekleştirmeye başlarız daha sonra
zihinsel gelişimle birlikte artık
çevreyi fark eden Bebek
bağlanabileceği annenin geri kalan
kısımlarını keşfetmeye başlar onun
koruyuculuğunu keşfetmeye başlar onun
ona verdiği şefkati sevgiyi kabul
edilebilirliği onayı bu ihtiyaçlarını
giderebilmek için bir serüvene girişir
Bunun yanına bir baba figürü de
eklendiği zaman Baba figürü ile birlikte
ortak anne figürünün kurduğu yaşamda
onlara ait olabilmek için onlar
tarafından sevilebilmek ve kabul
edilebilmek için bir yaşam mücadelesi
başlar
bu sağlıklı bir sistemde olan şeyler
fakat insan yaşamına baktığınız zaman
çok bu kadar dengeli ve sağlıklı
dinamiklere göre bilmeniz pek mümkün
olmaz o yüzden Aşkın dinamikleri
belirtileri birçok insanda aynı olmasına
rağmen
dinamik açıdan baktığınız zaman Aşkın
herkese ait ayrı bir serüveni vardır
Aynı belirtileri veririz ama
serüvenlerimiz farklılaşır işte bu
serilenlerimiz ilk bizim hayata gözleri
açtığımız andan itibaren başlar
doğar doğmaz kaybettiğimiz Ebeveynler
ebeveynini kaybeden İnsanlar bir
koruyucu figürü ondan alabileceği
sevgiyi ilgiyi kabul edilebilirliği
kaybetmiş olacak Yani aslında bir bakıma
terk edilmiş olacak bir çocuk ölümün
anlamını yaklaşık 7-8'li yaşlarda
kavramaya başlar soyutlama yeteneğinin
yani zihnin soyutlanma yeteneğinin
geliştiği dönemlerde ondan önce ölüm
kavramının içini yoktur
Ondan öncesinde bir ebeveyninden kaybı
bağlandığı bir ebeveynin kaybı Onun için
terk demektir
şunları kullanırız ya Annen Melek oldu
baban cennete gitti bu kavramlar çocuğun
zihninde terk anlamına gelir beni terk
etti ve daha iyi bir yer yaşadı yaşamak
üzere gitti peki bunun sorumlusunu
kendisine yorumlamaya başlayacak Demek
ki ben o kadar sevilebilir ve kabul
edilebilir biri değilim ki verilmenin
terk etti Daha iyi bir yere gitmeye
ihtiyacı duydu ve işte orada kendisini
kabul ettirme sebebini başlamış
olacaktır bunun tipik örneğinde şöyle
görürüz
kabul edilebileceğine inanamayan Bu
çocuk neden çünkü onu dünyaya getiren ve
onu sevmesi gereken yegane kişi bile onu
terk ettiğine göre dünya üzerinde artık
onu sevebilecek başka bir varlık daha
olamaz ve böylece sevilebiliriz ne test
etmeye başlar
onu Kabul edeceğini düşündüğü kişiyi
sınamaya başlayacak Bu bir artık sınava
dönüşecek ve bu sınavın içinde diğer
rakipler de oluşmaya başlayacak diğer
rakiplerin yanında bu sınavı başarıyla
birinci sırada tamamlayabilmek adına
mücadele verecek tipik bir örneğini
bunun evlat edinilen çocuklarda da
görebilirsiniz evlat edinilen çocuklar
evlatlık verildiği aileyi sınamaya
başlarlar o kadar çileden çıkarmaya
çalışırlar ki ama Bunun anlamı Ben sizi
istemiyorum demek değildir her şeye
rağmen beni kabul edebilecek misiniz
Bunu görmektir
Bu hayat öyküsünde bu kişinin artık
aşkla mücadelesi bununla başlamıştır ve
onun hayatına girip bağlanabileceği aşık
olduğu kişi kişiler onu en Zorlu
koşullarda sınavında bile yanındaki
olacak kişilerden seçmeye çalışacaktır
hepimizin ebeveyn figürleri var sadece
bu anne babayla da olmuyor nine dede
veya dalı Dayı hala Teyze amca gibi
birçok figürle bağlanma içine
girebiliyoruz hayatımızda bu kişilerin
ne kadar önemli rol oynadığına bağlı
olarak bu Herkesin kişisel yaşam öyküsü
değişir ve biz bu kişiler tarafından
kabul edilebilmek ve onay ihtiyar onay
alabilmek için onların istediği
karakterler olabilme yolunda ilerlemeye
başlarız
çok iyi bir çocuktu geçirdiğinizi
düşünebiliyor olabilirsiniz çocukken çok
sevildiğinizi düşünüyor olabilirsiniz
ama aşk kavramı ile birlikte ben bunları
bir daha sorgulamanızı isteyebilirim
sizden acaba Siz gerçekten seviliyor
muydunuz ebeveynleri sizi seviyorlar
mıydı veya sizin kendi zihinlerinde
olabilme ihtimaliniz kendi arzularını
tatmin edebilecek bir çocuk olabilme
ihtimalinizi mi seviyorlardı
Siz her halinizle kabul görebiliyor
muydunuz
Ya da sizin başarı sizi başarılı
olduğunuz için
Uslu olduğunuz için
iyi bir çocuk olabildiğiniz için mi
seviyorlardı ya da her şeye rağmen acaba
sevebilecekler miydi Aşkın temel
kavramlarından biri olan sevgi diye
tanımladığımız Şefkat diye
tanımladığımız bu duyguları sizi verecek
olan kişilerin sizden beklentilerini
karşılayamadığınız takdirde Acaba
gerçekten orada kalabilecek miydiniz
bu tek başına bir mücadeleyi başlatıyor
onların istediği gibi biri olabilmek
için
bir mücadele vereceğiz ve o mücadelenin
İçini rakiplerimiz de olacak
mutsuz bir anne
Depresyonda bir baba hasta bir ebeveyn
aile içindeki kavgalar sizi anlatılan
öyküler ya da şaka olduğu düşünülen
şeyler ne gibi seni camiye ablasında
bulduk seni hastanede karıştırmışız Bu
çocuk için
bir şaka değil aslında bir dramatik
durumu içerir çünkü
oraya ait hissetmemeye başlar ve beni
bir yerde buldukları için her an tekrar
oraya geri koyabileceklerini
düşündüğünden onlara tarafından kabul
görebilmek için inanılmaz bir mücadele
başlatır bu tarz öyküler bu tarz şakalar
çocuklar için hiç şaka olmayan ya da
tatlı bir öykü olmayan durum halini alır
ve bu acımasız sınavda Kendini kabul
ettirebilme onayını şefkati o sevgiyi
alabilme mücadelesinde yolunda kişi
hayatına koyacağı figürleri yine onu
zorlayabilecek onu test edebilecek
figürlerden seçmeye başlar
çoğu insan kendi ebeveynleri benzemek
istemez Hatta bazen tepkilerde bile
tepkili gösterir Hayır ben babamın
benzemek istemiyorum hayır ben anneme
benzemek istemiyorum Fakat babadan
alamadığınız şefkati ya da sevgiyi ya da
ilgiyi alabilme arzusuyla ona benzer
figürleri hayatımızı alabilmekten de
kaçınamayız veya annemizden alamadığımız
onayı hayatımıza alabileceğimiz biri
tarafından onaylanabilme arzusuyla
birlikte seçeceğimiz karakterin anneye
benzemesinden de kaçınamayabiliriz
İşte bunlar bizim aşık olduğumuz kişi
bizde yarattığı hissiyatların dinamik
olarak tanımlanmasına sağlayacak
yetersizliğimizin içinde mücadele
ediyoruz değersizliğimizin içinde
mücadele ediyoruz Bunlar Aslında bizim
yetersizliklerimiz değil bunlar bizim
değersizliklerimiz değil bunlar aslında
benim ebeveynlerimizin kendi içinde
yaşadıkları değersizlikleri yetersizleri
bizim üzerimizde tamamlama arzusundan
gelir ve o yüzden bizi bir bu inanılmaz
ve yorucu mücadelenin içine atarak
geride durup bizi eleştirmekle
yetinirler
hiçbir zaman asla onların istediği kadar
iyi olamayacaksın
ya da aşık olduğun kişinin
istediği kadar yeterli bir olamayacaksın
ya da o kişi sana asla o içinde boşluğu
içinde oluşan boşluğu doldurabilecek
kadar sevgiyi ya da şefkati ihtiyacın
olanı veremeyecek hiçbir zaman da tatmin
Olamayacağız
insan
öleceğini bilen tek Canla Dünya üzerinde
bir gün öleceğine bir gün yok olacağını
bilen tek canlı o zaman doğum ve ölüm
arasındaki yaşam süresine bir şekilde
doğru doldurmakta ve varoluşsal olarak
oraya bir şeyler katmak zorunda hisseden
bir canlı Biz varoluşsal kaygılarımızın
içinde varoluşumuzu anlamlandırmak için
mücadele ediyoruz ve bu varoluşa
anlamlandırabilmek için aşka ihtiyacı
duyuyoruz ve o aşk ne kadar kaotik
olursa o mücadele Bizi ölüme kadar
götürebilecek
hissiyatlar doğurmaya başlıyor haz
alıyoruz kaostan haz mı alıyoruz Evet
hazırlıyoruz
problem sorun acı bundan haz mı alıyoruz
Evet haz alıyoruz bunu biyolojik bir
sistemle de birleştirmek istiyorum
endorfin oksitosing İsmini verdiğimiz
hormonlar bağlanmayı sağlar heyecan
anında veya acı anında vücudun Ağrı
kesicisi gibi Rol oynamaya başlar ve siz
bir kez bunu tattığın tattığınız zaman
hayatınızda uyuşturucu madde bağımlısı
gibi yok maddeyi kullanmadın da
yoksunluk yaşayan bir kişinin
yoksunluğuna girip o maddeyi araması
gibi artık bunu aramaya başlarız acıyı
aramaya başlarız Aşk oksitesini
salgıladır endorfin salgılattırır haz
verir aşk acısı ayrılık acısı da haz
verir
aşkımızla birlikte bağlanma ile birlikte
aldığımız hazzı bizi duyurduktan sonra
bir daha onu alabilmek için bu sefer
Terk edilmeyi bekleriz terk edilmenin
hazzı ile birlikte de bu ikisi
birleştiğinde kaotik bir yaşamda
Aşkımıza karşılık alabilmek terk
edildiğimizde onu tekrar elde
edebilmenin
heyecanıyla hazzı ile Hayatımıza devam
ettirmeye başlarız
çocuk oyun seven bir varlık Hayat çocuk
için bir oyun ama içimizde hiç büyümeyen
O çocuğun her zaman oynamak istediği bir
oyun var
oyun oynarken takıldığımız yerlerde
zihnimiz orayı aşabilmek için bir daha
dönmek ister bir daha dönmek bir daha
dönmek ister babadan alınamayan şefkati
alabilmek için oraya bir daha döner O
yüzden ona benzer karakter seçer anneden
alınamayan onaya geri dönüp orayı
çözebilmek için anneye benzer karakter
seçer çocuk için bunların hepsi bir
oyundan ibarettir ve biz büyüdükçe
Aslında
takıldığımız yere yani geçmişe tekrar ve
tekrar dönme ihtiyacı hissediyoruz ve bu
sorunun çözümünü karşı tarafta oraya
uygun çözemediğimiz kişilere uygun
karakterlere seçtiğimizde oraya
çözebildiğimizde O çocukluktaki engeli
de aşabileceğime inanıyoruz
Bu yüzden aşklar bir döngü içinde devam
etmeye hep benzer karakterler seçmeye
başlıyoruz hepiniz hayatınızda şöyle
dönüp eski aşklarınıza şu anki
aşklarınıza bakın birbirine benzer o
kadar noktaya kalacaksınız ki onları bir
de ebeveynlerinizle eşleştirmeye çalışın
ortak noktalar bulabileceğinizi
düşünüyorum Bu sizin aşamadığınız bir
yerde
karşılanamayan ihtiyaçlarınızın
yetersizliklerinizin
değersizliklerinizin kabul edilebilir mi
ihtimalinin bir oyunlaştırılmış haline
dönüşüyor insanın temelinde iki tane
duygu var dikkat etmemiz gereken aşkı
şekillendiren bir utançtır biri
suçluluktur
Eğer anne Babanız tartışma içindeyse
çocuk bunun onu o dünyaya geldikten
sonra olduğuna İnanır ve mutsuzluğun
kaynağını kendisi olduğunu düşün
ür hasta ebeveyn o dünyaya geldiği için
hasta olduğuna İnanır ve kendisini
suçlamaya başlar şu an baktığımız zaman
yetişkinlik hayatımızda hep
karşıyayızdir kendimizi rahatlatmak için
ama çocukluğunuza bir dönüp bakıp Eğer
gerçekten İçindeki Çocuğu keşfetmeye
çalışırsanız
kendisini suçladığı noktaları
gördüğünüzde
çocuk o kendi suçluluğunu çözümü için
hayatında aşk aramaya başlar
Hayat bir oyun gibi ise biz bize
yüklenen Gelecek kaygısı nedeniyle
geleceğimizi değiştirmeye çalıştığımızı
düşünüyoruz fakat bizim Aslında
değiştirmeye çalıştığımız yer geçmişimiz
Bunun için çaba harcıyoruz geçmişi
değiştirmek biliyoruz mümkün değil
Geçmişi değiştirebilmek adına geçmişteki
Benzer şeyleri tekrar ve tekrar
yaşıyoruz
bu tekrar ve tekrar yaşamın içinde bunu
çözebilme umuduyla da aşkı buluyoruz
Dilerim ki siz bunu çözebilirsiniz onu
çözebilecek aşkı bulursunuz o yüzden
hepinize Aşk olsun diyorum